I imagine that our political class that
you're the president of America Obama
simply would say at least about Russia
look there's not much that we can do and
why should be you know Ukraine whatever
is simply not a prime economic or
political interest so you know why
should we open the box of Pandora and
get whatever you know and and let us be
realistic because what you call double
standards in political terms it's called
political realism we heard these
arguments seventy-five years ago why the
British soldiers should die for a
country they couldn't find a map and
policy of appeasement always fails when
you are dealing with a dictator that is
just is getting more and more arrogant
with weakness and indecisiveness from
our side the world as I said it's
already globalized and you cannot
separate problems in Ukraine from
problems of North Korea or elsewhere
because you know information travels
instantly and I remember that after this
Obama's infamous red line failure in
Syria I said that was a disaster not
just for this region but also for other
facts in the world because they could
learn that American president was
willing to back off what they call
ironically leading from behind just fine
of Enochs immoral leading from behind so
and there's no vacuum in politics or
geopolitics you walk away
somebody gets in I was inspired by a
speech but I have just one question and
that is you said that we should stand up
and defeat the Dick toriel toriel
regimes if I'm not wrong but you also
said that history goes in seasons and
kind of repeats itself what do you think
we will accomplish with defeating
these regimes and don't you think that
new ones will stand up
no but seasons you know it's right but
it's it's it's it's a spiral but spiral
goes up so that's why it's basically
what I said each generation has its own
duties so actually you know I believe
you know I would probably fight today is
not as harsh as 60 years ago and when
somebody tells me Oh Putin's too
dangerous to confront are you sure he's
more dangerous than Joseph Stalin 1948
when Harry Truman ordered airlifting
supply to West Berlin besieged as West
Berlin and for 11 months American and
British players have been supplying West
Berliners with everything they needed
and Stalin hasn't shot a single a single
American play I don't British plane
because I guess he realized that Harry
Truman was not a man to to confront with
so we have again it's a different
challenge because we have suicide
bombers we have most likely I will be
facing rock States with nuclear weapons
it's a different kind of challenge but
you know we have to find a way to fight
them and to defeat them to make sure
that the human race will go to a new new
season otherwise the winter might be you
know might become a nuclear winter
you've already mentioned the film that
has been shown last week on the Russian
television about the Crimea and
annexation of it in the film put in
actually threatens of using nuclear
weapons what do you think on that is
that real threat or is he bluffing I
mean I wish I knew the answer yeah again
you know probably there is no answer
because this answer should you know be
timed why Putin said it because he could
see that for 20 years a rogue regime in
North Korea who terrorized the world
with a bucket of nuclear waste and the
whole world has been dancing around you
know just feeding poor people in in in
North Korean gulag because this disease
is ok father now the son or actually is
already grandson so the
a generation of these schemes there they
they learn how to use nuclear blackmail
now from Putin's perspective if you can
be so successful using this nuclear
Pinner of this waste so how about you
know threatening the world with the
largest or second largest nuclear
arsenal again it worked and that's the
problem with dictators well it works
they become more arrogant you know it's
when you just look at the history of the
world war two I mean it's it's clear
that it's from his perspective there was
no difference between Poland and
Czechoslovakia if they gave up
Czechoslovakia why did if any Poland so
it's psychological what's the difference
so at certain point you know it's we
reached we reach the line but if we let
dictator to move too far he could get so
crazy that he could you know believe
that it worked and I doubt very much
it's a serious read because you know in
Russia it's not just Putin to push the
button there are many other people
that's why I've been arguing for a year
to ignore Putin and to address others
because he has it burned all the bridges
but many others are still you know
contemplating whether they have to
follow his crazy orders or not so make
sure they understand the guy's crazy and
there is a future without without him
mr. Kasparov it's a great honor
you mentioned winter's coming
you also said in the beginning of your
speech Europe must not fall this morning
my younger brother receives a letter
from the Ministry of Defense from
Netherlands and which it was stated he's
eligible for military service
this is already abandoned in the
Netherlands but other European countries
have already reintroduced military
service do you think we are too ignorant
in the Netherlands can say concerning
such policies should we get ready for
military service for duty the answer is
yes it doesn't mean that it will end up
with with combat in this in the
battlefield but you know if you're too
late you know it you know it could as I
said increase the price because the
threats are obvious and you know
what can stop the the Putin's aggression
or the expansion of the evil forces is
is our strength dictators are have great
animal instincts they can smell when
they can move forward or they can just
you know they have withhold their
intentions and you know strengths of
europe united europe could in my view
provide enough momentum if not for putin
forget him he burned all the bridges but
that many people surrounding him that
they'll recognize that europe is not is
no longer indifferent to this reds
because you may ignore ii crane but at
one point you know you have to deal with
Estonia Latvia so other native countries
and the moment Europe fails to protect
one smallest nation that is under NATO
umbrella the whole concept is dead and
adding it will undo the great work of
Europe by bringing together nations by
creating institutions by respecting the
borders this is those are the things
that are so vital for the report for the
rest of the world and to let it go I
think will will lead to a true disaster
I have a question on your Facebook page
you've recently criticized President
Barack Obama for only mentioning Russia
and it's vulnerable economic state sort
of not really doing much about it and
you ended your caption by saying Ukraine
needs weapons not words so my question
to you is aren't you afraid that with
Putin being a guy with easy access to
nuclear weapons this will throw Ukraine
and Russia down the rabbit hole if
America arms Ukraine I don't think that
if Putin believes for a moment that he
needs more blood and Ukraine to improve
his domestic standings he will look for
for a pretext he doesn't need American
weapons to justify his further
aggression does American weapons and
we're talking airing a very very small
amount of Mothe lethal
military helped to put to be provided it
mainly right Radio electronics devices
and and and and and anti-tank missiles
I'm sure any American military base
could provide what Ukraine asked so it's
a will it stop Putin's attack no but it
it will dramatically raise the price
that he will have to pay it may still
not be enough but that's the it's it's
like you know it's not a game of chess
or mathematics you know that it's just
you could calculate but definitely you
improve your odds and knowing Putin's
behavior you know he will attack if he
if he smells witness not if he if he
knows that it could be the price is
going high also I think it's very
important psychologically it's America's
leading not from behind but leading in
supplying weapons to Ukraine can help
Ukraine to get support in Europe NATO
will not do it as an organization but
many European nations are still holding
even supply of all Soviet equipment to
to Ukraine because America is is not in
so I think psychologically to help you
know the morale of Ukrainians it will
help European allies and it will also
send a signal to the Russian generals
because at the end of the day they have
to follow Putin's commands and
recognizing that they will be fighting
Ukrainian army trained and even on the
limited scale supported by Americans who
create a very different very different
psychological momentum there it may not
stop for the bloodshed moreover I'm
convinced that put it will continuous
attacks just because he needs you know
he needs war drugs you know like a drug
user you know Crimean Crimean you for is
over you can look at this and this
pathetic demonstration in Moscow where
people were paid and still it was far
less impressive the anniversary of
Crimea annexation then the funeral of
Boris themself then where people just
came you know just on their own so Putin
needs more adrenaline
to to to to to the nation and I will
gonna be surprised if further tax on
Ukraine will will will be considered as
the only way to boost his peace
popularity you talked about trading
individual freedom for stability one of
the effects of terror attacks like 9/11
is that national intelligence agencies
have gotten a lot more power to do
surveillance stuff like that this is an
effect trading individual privacy and
freedom force the the promise of
stability so my question to you is do
you think that the power that is given
to these intelligence agencies is
helping us against the war on terror and
dictatorships or do you think that it's
throwing under the bus these crucial
modern values that you are talking about
that's a political dialectics and I have
been saying that you know it's it's it's
a fight again it's a seasonal fight so
you can't accept the demands without big
debate so you can't accept demands of
security officers saying we need more
power
everything should be investigated and
it's like a pendulum you know sometimes
it pushes one way then you can just you
know you can try to push it another way
that's that's called democracy and and I
said you know that's the naturally the
response for aggressive speech is more
more more freedom of speech so while I
do understand that it's impossible now
with this you know with this modern
communication to guarantee the total
privacy though I'm you know I'm in favor
of protecting the First Amendment of US
Constitution as a number one factor of
securing our freedom but it's again it's
this is a subject for you know for for
political debate so as long as we have
we live in a free society there will be
always in a push of this pendulum one
side or another right now I'm writing a
paper about Belarus and I was wondering
what your opinion is of what the EU
could have done difference during the
jeans revolution in 2006
I doubt very much that Belarusian sad
situation Belarusian could have changed
as long as Moscow was sort of the
constant supply of free energy and sort
of political backup when needed
so Lukashenko knew that with Putin and
his back so he could do almost anything
he wanted as long as he you know play
the role of the not younger brother but
you know a member of the family so the
biggest mistake towards Bella Russia was
for Europe and America to call
Lukashenko the last dictator of Europe
ignoring the fact that you know he was
very much byproduct of what's happened
in Russia do you see any change from
outside not from inside so if Putin's
regime comes to the end to an end then
it's because there is too much present
from outside not from with from with him
the Putin regime reached the state were
you know legitimate constitutional
nonviolent means well not in his power
he's going to stay for the rest of his
life I always said that while I didn't
have a crystal ball I couldn't see the
future you know I can predict one thing
for sure
Putin will die in Kremlin so when and
how nobody knows it would be him so
that's that's a problem of all the
dictators so is the I think this is at
that point the outside pressure is vital
because it should create enough cracks
in the monolith of power it should send
signals both to the elite and also to
Russian middle class that it will not
end unless they do something so Russia
will be thinking deeper deeper and
deeper into their beefs of this paranoia
so eventually it will happen from inside
but the strong opposition to the regime
is vital because you know it's you know
the the entire Putin's
we're staying in powers based on his on
the demonstration of strengths abroad so
that's like a Putin's new mythology he
doesn't need any more stability he
doesn't care about economic standards in
Russia so we just it's all being dropped
it's all all these cards thrown away
Putin's Putin's power today Russia based
on his match image of invincible
dictator who who can bring the entire
world under under under it's its knees
so destroying this myth will eventually
destroy Putin's routes to power Russia I
have a simple question in life in war
and chest what is the better answer to
offense defense or offense basically
it's an invitation for a new lecture
because it's about it's about please
keep it simple it's it's about a playing
style it and I I wrote the whole book
how life imitate chess when I explained
you know that it's it's the answer is
always inside so I'm arguing for
attackers advantage that's that's that's
the name of one of my chapters because
the way I was built but you know just
remember that whatever you do you know
you have to make sure that you
comfortable with these decisions and you
know being a very aggressive player like
in tennis you know powerful serve
rushing to the net doesn't mean that you
will beat someone who plays from the
back line nobody in your honor in your
opinion no but I'm yeah my you know I I
was always looking for for more
aggressive approach because I believe
that you know you have to be ahead of
the curve
I never believed in leading from behind
thank you